c'est amateur de trottinette le sait il
n'a pas le droit d'être dans cette piste
cyclable en fait ni ici ni ailleurs
selon l'état actuel de la loi si vous
êtes propriétaire d'un tel appareil
électrique une trottinette électrique ou
une planche à roulette électrique
présentement vous aviez pas le droit de
rouler nulle part vous aviez pas le
droit d'être le trottoir vous aviez pas
le droit d'être dans la rue vous avez
peur pas le droit d'être sur des pistes
cyclables Québec corrige la situation et
encadre la circulation avec un projet
pilote de 3 ans la nouvelle
réglementation concernera pas seulement
les trottinettes électriques mais aussi
les planches à roulettes les véhicules
gyroscopiques à une roue vitesse
maximale 25 km/h ces appareils pourront
aller sur la voie publique et aussi dans
des pistes cyclables qui sont bien
séparées de la chaussée c'est une bonne
chose d'ailleurs j'entendais que on va
être obligé de porter le casque pour
tout ce qui est électrique tant mieux et
pour les appareils sans guidon coudière
genouillère et gants seront exigés aussi
quant à la cohabitation on ne permet pas
rien sur les trottoirs ce qui est une
très bonne nouvelle pour la chercheur
sur les piétons que je suis mais c'est
certain qu'il y a une cohabitation qui
va être un apprentissage pour tout le
monde pour accueillir tous ces véhicules
Vélo-Québec voudrait que toute nouvelle
piste cyclable soit comme le réseau
express vélo avec un seul sens de
circulation des pistes cyclables comme
on les voit ici avec des vitesses
différentes toutes sortes d'engins à
chaque dépassement c'est un risque de
collision frontale pourquoi est-ce que
Québec a choisi la voie du projet pilote
ça va nous permettre de voir les bons
points et également peut-être les choses
à corriger en cours de route s'il y
avait par exemple des éléments dans la
réglementation qui ne cadraient pas avec
certaines utilisations mais il n'est pas
question pour autant du retour des
trottinettes en libre-service comme
elles ont brièvement existé à Montréal
par exemple
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal